in Avengers infinity war Thanos wages
war on our superheroes as he hunts down
the Infinity stones for his master plan
of rebalancing the universe was a power
of the Infinity Gauntlet yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers it's Jan here and right now
five of the six Infinity stones are
accounted for in the MCU which means the
whereabouts of the soul stone is still
unknown so today I'm breaking down in
detail how where and when we'll likely
see the soul stone in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I'm examining
evidence for the movies and theories you
can see on the screen now and this
timecode links in the video description
if you want to jump forward to any
particular theory if you've just
discovered my channel I do regular
Marvel and superhero videos and today
I'm starting a new Avengers giveaway to
enter tap the Bell and let me know in
the comments below where you think the
soul stone will appear by the way I'll
be announcing the winner of my Black
Panther giveaway later in this video
spoiler warning I'll be talking about
Black Panther previous MCU movies and
speculating on upcoming movies including
infinity war atman and the wasp Captain
Marvel and Avengers for there were
plenty of popular theories before black
panther was released that the movie
would reveal the soul stone was in
Wakanda
if you've seen the film you know that
didn't happen however there's still a
chance that the stone is hidden
somewhere in the African nation we know
from black panthers prologue that were
canada's vibranium came from a meteorite
that hit the earth and then affected the
plant life there's quite a convincing
theory that the sole stone is buried
deep in the center of the meteorite and
it's that Infinity stone which gives the
heart-shaped herb its extraordinary
properties this soul stone theory could
also explain why the plant gives the
person who ingests it access the
ancestral plane and the ability to
communicate with the souls of the dead
by the way the soul stone and dying the
heart-shaped herb with its powers would
also fit the Thanos theory and I'll
explain what that means later for those
who don't already know one potential
problem with this theory is that the
soul stone is orange colored whereas the
heart-shaped herb is purple
however the colors of the Infinity
stones and the powers they grant do not
always have to match scarlet which for
example derives her powers from the
yellow mine stone but her
powers are read and when we first
encounter the mind stone in Loki's
scepter it looks blue but later when
it's broken open the stones true yellow
color is revealed
there is a potential wrinkle in this
theory though which is that black
panther director Ryan Coogler has
specifically said about the soul stone
that I left the Infinity stones as much
as any comic book fan it's just what
Kanda already has its thing which is
vibranium but us that was special enough
so to throwing something like another
special thing didn't feel right it felt
like we should stick with our one
MacGuffin for the country and explore
that and Marvel Studios was never really
interested in putting a stone in there
either now that makes total sense as the
movie gave us an awesome introduction to
a Kanda and it had a lot to pack into
its runtime so if they had to also
include and explain the soulstone it
might have all felt like a bit too much
and taking the shine away from the main
story just in order to set up a future
story but let's remember that Kugler is
only talking about his own black panther
solo movie here and so Marvel might
still choose to reveal that the soul
stone is in Wakanda in their next film
Avengers infinity war okay let's get
into the Infinity stone theories for
that movie we've seen quite a bit of
footage of Thanos sending a huge army of
outriders to invade work and ER and
because we know he's trying to complete
his Infinity Gauntlet it seems highly
possible that he's after an infinity
stone among a range of infinity war LEGO
sets a two different infinity stone
scene set in Wakanda in one set you can
see one of thanasis Black Order Proxima
midnight trying to steal an orange
looking stone a link description for the
lego set also specifically says that
Falcon is diving down to save the soul
stone while in another Lego set we can
clearly see Captain America and Black
Widow defending a blue infinity stone
against an outrider now you have to bear
in mind that these are toy sets and they
might be actual scenes or fairly close
to actual scenes all the toy designers
may have just mixed up different
elements for the movie to create an
enticing product to sell I do think
we'll probably get at least one Infinity
stone turning up when work and ruin
infinity war however it might just be
the mind stone because we know from the
trail
the black order attempt to extract that
from visions forehead so the Avengers
may take him to a candor for treatment
so it can be removed without killing him
we also know from the Avengers infinity
war prelude comic and the black panther
post-credit scene that Sheree has
developed Tech in Wakanda that removed
the Hydra programming from Bucky's brain
and I think she may well find a way to
treat vision as well however we can't
ignore that Thanos may simply be
invading work and ER for access to all
that precious vibranium and tech which
T'Challa was about to announce to the
world and the first Black Panther and
credits scene another alternate location
for the soulstone and infinity war is
the Red Planet need of alia this planet
which is inhabited by dwarves is where
mule near was originally forged and an
infinity war it looks like Thor travels
there with the guardians to create a new
weapon there's actually a Lego set of a
scene from the planet and it shows an
infinity stone being used for what it
calls a space Forge
it's from the scene in the trailer where
we briefly see Thor straining to control
a machine this Infinity stone might or
might not be the soul stone but I think
it's interesting that thoughts how
immune there was to quote Odin forged in
the heart of a dying star and if that
heart of a dying star is the location of
the soul stone this would also fit the
phallus theory okay before we get too
attached to the idea that the soul stone
must either be in Wakanda or somewhere
else in Avengers infinity war let's look
at some theories that Marvel could be
saving the soul stone for use in a film
after infinity war the next film after
Avengers infinity war is ant-man and the
wasp and what we know so far is that the
movie will travel to the quantum realm
we haven't seen very much of the quantum
realm yet in the MCU with just glimpses
and Doctor Strange and the first ant-man
movie
so if Marvel felt they wanted the story
and box-office payoff from the reveal of
a new infinity stone in ant-man and the
wasp rather than Avengers infinity war
the quantum realm would be a good place
to explain where the soul stones been
all these years
and there's actually a precedent in the
comics for an infinity stone existing at
the subatomic level in a 1980s
Incredible Hulk storyline Bruce Banner
travelled to the subatomic world of Chi
where he encountered an elder of the
universe called the gardener
that time the gardener was in possession
of an infinity gem and had traveled to
KY in order to keep the power of the gem
away from humanity I certainly wouldn't
expect this story to play out exactly
like this in Atman and the wasp
however Scott Lang and hope Van Dyne
could encounter a new elder of the
universe who controls or have access to
the soul stone after all the elders of
the universe have already been
introduced in the MCU in the form of the
collector and the Grandmaster and it
looks like the quantum realm will play a
crucial role in linking all the movies
between infinity war and Avengers 4
because the subatomic world that Ant Man
and the wasp explores will also connect
specifically to the Captain Marvel movie
and the rest of the MCU quantum
physicists dr. spero Sneha lacus who
worked as a consultant on ant-man has
confirmed this link between the movies
and has also suggested that once
superheroes like admin and the wasp and
perhaps Captain Marvel begin to
understand quantum code they'll be able
to access powers that are considered
impossible in the normal world the
instance they could in theory manipulate
the physical laws of the universe like
space and time to create things like
black holes and such powers would
clearly be very useful if you're up
against the likes of Thanos but it
really makes me wonder whether the
soulstone could be connected to these
potential new powers and abilities and
finally we come to the mother of all MCU
movies the epic finale to everything
that Marvel Studios has been building to
Avengers 4 so what we have to wait till
then to see the soulstone well we know
from various set photos that it looks
like the movie will incorporate time
travel and that ties back nicely to why
the movies ant-man and the wasp and
Captain Marvel have been placed between
infinity war and Avengers 4 as the
exploration of the quantum realm in
those two films could open up the
ability for other Avengers beyond Doctor
Strange to mess with the timeline and
potentially prevent Thanos attaining
supremacy and it's possible that
Avengers 4 could be an attempt by the
Avengers to recover the soul stone
before Thanos gets to it first okay I
can't finish without mentioning that
it's still possible the soulstone has
been hiding in plain sight ever since
the first Thor movie in other words it's
located in the middle of Heimdall 'he's
armor or even in his
which is one possible reason of his
glowing orange eyes and the fact he can
see trillions of souls
Heimdall having the soul stone also ties
in nicely with the Thanos theory which I
mentioned earlier there's all the
objects holding the Infinity stones in
the MCU will eventually spell out the
word Thanos so far we've had the
tesseract at4 the space stone the ether
and a for the reality stone dr.
strangers eye of agamotto is held on a
necklace giving an end for the time
stone the orb which contains the power
stone provides an O and Loki's scepter
which help the mine stone gives us an S
so Heimdall heart-shaped herb or heart
of a dying star would all provide the
missing H for the Thanos theory if the
soul stone were in Heimdall then Thanos
could take it when he attacks the US
guardianship after thor ragnarok
and if Thanos had to kill Heimdall to
get the stone that might lead to Loki
offering Thanos the tesseract in order
to spare the rest of the Asgardians now
I want to know where you think the soul
stone is going to appear and do you have
any predictions on how it will be used
let me know what you think in the
comments below and make sure you also
subscribe for your chance to win my
Avengers Funko pop giveaway the winner
of my Black Panther giveaway is on
screen right now so if that's you make
sure you private message me with your
details if you liked this I really
appreciate your support so hit the
thumbs up button and share the video
plus you can tap the bell to get all my
new videos as soon as I post them and
check out either of the links here for
more Marvel and Black Panther thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers